fa vj che torna su scribblenauts sta per
finire il mondo bella a tutti i ragazzi
e benvenuti in questo nuovo video io
sono faringei ed oggi
dio mio siamo su scribblenauts dopo non
miri ma forse sono tre o quattro mesi
centro gioca a scriverlo no vabbè
ragazzi la vostra reazione per chi
seguiva la serie la reazione sarà stata
questa
avevo detto che l'episodio successivo
che avrei fatto su scribblenauts sarebbe
stato quello finale perché l'aver
giocato finché non sarebbe finito quindi
non sapendo quanto sarebbe durato
l'episodio è dato che ci metto secoli a
fare cose del genere non avevo mai ho
voglia o tempo di farlo perché impiega
veramente tantissimo però finalmente
sono riuscito a farlo è direi di
continuare dove c'erano rimasti ragazzi
non mi ricordo neanche più come si gioca
abisso all'interazione eravamo qui non
mi ricordo neanche più che lo stavo
facendo siamo sott'acqua e dobbiamo
sbloccarci la nuova zona con 50 st
wright a quante sarai chiamo bull che ne
so io spero così come si fa vedere
quanto esso wright siamo non lo so
raga e allora aspettate a ok 40 dei
ragazzi dobbiamo arrivare
devo fare troppe st wright in questo
video perfetto devo farne 6 e sbloccarmi
d'antona finale puoi definire la zona
finale perfetto ragazze ce la possono
fare uno scalo che dorme non so perché
ma non vorrei svegliarlo ma vediamolo
mal di denti dami qualcosa per curarli
uno squalo col mal di denti originale mi
viene proprio da ridere collutorio
velenoso a caso fa così a baby
avvelenati cosenza horvath utenti sta
bene ragazzi siamo a posto perché
abbandonato questo gioco e fantastici
adesso ci manca solo che si mangi il
dentista allora ragazzi non ha scuse
perché c'è il professor layton fatto
squalo e big daddy di baio so che lui
c'è una fuoriuscita di combustibile che
sa qualcosa per tappare condotto tappo
gigante tappo gigante place di sughero
di sughero vai così il condotto è giusto
è un pozzo petrolifero spontaneo si
tappato con un tappo di sughero mi
sembra giusto
rega ci siamo la prima star e il figlio
oggi devo allora aiuta licenziate a
creare una catena alimentare da studiare
sì problema con la il dubbio che vi
sorge la domanda che mi sorge spontanea
proprio fare e perché minchia dovete
farlo sott'acqua soprano andava bene
aiuta lo scienziato a cominciare una
catena alimentare sott'acqua giusto che
ha dapprima una fonte energetica
inesauribile
forse i suoi il sole
direi che sono sole sole sole stella
stella va bene stella ok questa va bene
come fonte energetica va bene come fonte
energetica inesauribile sott'acqua mi
sembra giusto che le stelle cristiano
sott'acqua che cazzo sta succedendo una
balena morta perfetto ragazzi sto gioco
sta scendendo nel non stance a livelli
improponibile crea una forma di vita la
base della catena alimentare che
utilizzi quell'energia con molta
fantasia io scrivo pesce è quindi
vediamo se va bene ok questo perché mi
veniva altra va bene così è un imbarazzo
ci stanno invadendo bene allora cosa
devo fare come ultimo obiettivo infine
crea un predatore in cima alla catena
alimentare che mangi qualsiasi cosa
ok questo chip questo lo so questo lo so
fa vj ok mai cos'è
va bene non lo so perché allora pa vj
carnivoro bene ad ogni avvio questa è la
cosa più brutta che abbia mai visto
ragazzi sono diventato un mangia pesce è
una cosa veramente brutta sto mangiando
di tutto però vabbè il santi papi
lascia perdere ci penso io un predatore
nella squalo squalo
brusco molto brutto vai così scuola
cantica schifo e squalo è questo ok ce
l'ho fatta ragazzi una storia e teoria
bene
veramente non so perché avevo smesso di
giocare a scriver nostro perché troppo
figo
peccato che oggi e finirà tutto così la
smettete di chiedermelo spiaggia di am x
sandro non so che cosa mandiamoci perché
va bene e già meglio con stesso perché
c'è un bagnino sott'acqua cos'è ragazzi
cosa sta succedendo chi è quello che
einstein james benissimo c'è una
spiaggia con einstein perché i ragazzi
perché ci einstein in spiaggia perché in
spiaggia è normale che c'è gente con un
gran fisico non faceva ridere verona
bene allora ragazzi c'è elvis presley
che magari vs asd divertente di me
abbiamo bisogno di un altro concorrente
prix rality show ciano reality ma perché
non mi avete chiamato prima perché elvis
perché c'è garda ragazzi e vabbè
benvenuto le sull'isola dei
sopravvissuti prepara il fuoco per
accendere per accedere al prossimo turno
va bene alla lo fa nel fuoco la vita
facile accendino è chiaro che è facile
così bene ce la siamo in grande sono il
primitivo più fantastico del quello che
la lente sì ma tu sei indietro zio
io vado con gli accendini sono più
avanti c'è gandalf che farà la magia
io veramente non ho parole
chi è chi è cosa facile perché perché
c'è un motivo di temi perché tra
chiedevi deve accendersi un legno se li
tiri un calcio perché quello incassato è
se eliminato zio mi dispiace sei stupido
perché la fisica c'è mai da einstein
fatti spiegare come si accende il fuoco
tirandoci calci rimangono tra i
concorrenti trova un modo per rendere
l'armadillo esteticamente più
interessante al pubblico da casa
io devo devo fare il trucco a un
armadillo cioè io io adesso devo rifarmi
pingi di più vai ad esso stesso
siamo rimasti con due concorrenti crea
un oggetto simile si aggiunge trio lino
che delle
buongiorno a lato
cioè io io ragazzi io non voglio pensare
che cosa diavolo c'è nella testa dei
creatori di questo gioco c'è grande ha
vinto io l'ho a latera molto più
semplice
va bene gandalf ha perso mi spiace zio
non sei capace e torna nella terra di
mer di mordor perché non sei capace
bravo vinto samhain 2013 edition of
cibernauta limiti di fa vj con lastre
write
raga siamo a 3 aiuto non so nuotare ed
il bagnino dorme ma non sei tu il
bagnino a anno al bagnino e quello
straiato lì che si fa in casa ciccio a
ok allora catena perfetto strumento che
ci siamo era fissiamo al piedino sua
lega è perfetto che ci siamo poi
incudine ragazzi lo stiamo aiutando la
perfezione è pro vige risolve la
situazione un'altra volta
benissimo adesso che ti aiutato spero
che tu sia più felice va bene va bene
dai ti aiuto perché non sei kv eni qui
brutto stronzo ti aiuto io perché sennò
come muore
bene adesso sento sei a posto io sono
vero bagnino grazie bagni nel servizio
si sono io aiutaci a creare un nuovo
gioco darci qualcosa lancia l'altra rete
che non sia una palla bomba non lo so
niente di questa vai così spero vi vada
bene ragazze pallavolo non convenzionale
ok maxwell guy come avatar non
interessava bene ragazzi io non
giocherei mai a pallavolo con una bomba
aiuti a mais non mettere in orbita il
mio satellite non c'è niente di meglio
di lui ragazzi anche nell'ultimo
episodio il trampolino il trampolino di
scribblenauts giacché le notti episodio
vai cos'è ci dovremmo essere cosa che
non va dello zero buttato in orbita cosa
c'è che non va ancora pieni vuoi andare
anche tu a controllare che sia in orbita
va bene accomodati bene è vero che ti
vada bene questo ok un grande passo per
la scienza la scienza secondo fa vj e
meglio il trampolino era il modo giusto
ma va bene così
quando ce ne sono due ragazzi prendo ste
due poi abbiamo sul mercato la zona
finale perché ormai siamo a quarantotto
benvenuto a voi il carbo calcano bocca
al cam nou perfetto c'è anche indiana
jones
c'è una gallina c'è un dio mio
ma cosa c'è
ma chi cazzo vabbè d'amico è cosa da
lanciare al mio cane
io direi osso ma gigante perché non è
che siete proprio piccoli
mi sembra di vedere no obesa o pensa 5
no no la casa perché mano ragazzi io
perché il bambino zio gemma in questa è
la cosa no io non ho parole per
descrivere il suo gioco va piloti dirti
che cosa sei frodo hai bisogno
dell'anello ho dimenticato da sotto per
il settore nel vulcano no veramente è
l'anello l'hai perso
vai vai vai buttano vota pollica
io vi giuro che non sa non ho parole ma
matteo da abbandonato scrive l'ansa
fantastico se va bene io non chi è
questa chi sei olimpiadi xena genivi
lontano dai quattro cavalieri
dell'apocalisse va bene cioè io
veramente non so che cosa mi stavo
perdendo perché non ho figli giocare
agli studi i cavalieri dell'apocalisse
blocca la malattia portata dalla
pestilenza
va bene che cosa dovrei fare
ok
non lo so medicina top questa è la cura
alla pestilenza mondiale c'è grande
famiglia risolversi prima andato
grandissimo in prossima è un bianco
sembra non lo so veramente mi sembra un
bambino travestito da halloween
la malattia è passata ma è scoppiata la
guerra trova un modo per fermarla c'è
una cosa che mette d'accordo tutti
quanti nel mondo e della cioccolata
perfetto
ok ci dovremmo essere coppa la guerra
vivo la cioccolata questo è un nuovo
slogan ioni cosa sta succedendo va beh
la guerra è finita ma la carestia al
solito le riserve di cibo trova da
mangiare per i nativi hanno mangiato la
cioccolata di prima cioè io non ho fatto
nulla stavolta ho fatto da sola bene
così andiamo col prossimo dai che ci
siamo quasi sono tutti morti cose qual è
l'ultima sfida nonostante la
disponibilità di cibo sono morti trova
ma dopo riportarli in vita theo dove sai
quando serve vai porta li invita vai
così peggio del rianimatore ragazzi ci
siamo ragazzi bye mama mia è lui che è
in grado di riportare in vita tutti
quanti e ci risiamo allara st wright 49
raga ci stiamo avvicinando alla fine di
stringe manca una st wright benissimo
raga ce la devo fare assolutamente rega
l'ultima asta wright devo riuscire a
trovarla ok ho trovata perfette questa
calmi perché c'è una spada su
un'incudine non mi interessa salva il
viaggio dal bulbi villaggio si il
viaggio aveda vulcano che sta per
aiutare bene lui prima volta che l'ho
visto fare era da goku in dragon ball gt
e ce la posso fare anch'io alla rotonda
energetica e quello che è bastato
l'ultima volta spero basti anche adesso
ragazzi sta eruttando tutto bene il
vulcano s'apre ruttare salva il
villaggio dello sciamano sacrificando
oggetti alla dea vulcano scrivi tra
idonei alla dea della dea terra da
gettare nel vulcano bene allora io
proporrei l'anello perché prima il frodo
l'ha lanciato in modo sbagliato quindi
ci dovremmo c'è
bello andava bene o rosa che vi chiamo
dell'oro a caso mai così perfetto poi
finire scrive lo ti prego ma per farlo
offro il sacrificio la cosa più preziosa
al mondo che lo è la vj vai così si fa
vj è sacrificato perfetto dalla ci
dovremmo essere ci sono le tre sto
ancora morendo ma in fretta perfetto
l'attività l'ebook anno aumenta forse la
da vulcano vuole sacrificio in denaro
grana donazione per il vulcano va bene
facciamo l'otto per mille a vulcan al
vulcan tattoo che non mi vengono idee
mandate un sms con scritto mi son rotto
il cazzo
al 48 2014 enti sia faccio io va bene
accetti carta di credito cosa carta di
credito di crei o cosa ho scritto carta
di credito bene vabbè va bene con la
carta si placa il pagamento in carta lo
accetta va benissimo se sei ricca
bravissima va bene poi la blocco però
vabbè non importa basta che finisce star
più da mista st wright che me la sto
sudando anche perché fa un caldo boia
chi è quella da offerte non hanno
funzionato e va bene però da del vulcano
apparse vuole uno spasimante il cra
qualcuno con cui sarà felice direi
cupido ragazzi saranno felici di cupido
e la deh del vulcano saranno felici
insieme mi fa molto piacere elevate
vidar cava bene reagan o no si sono
suicidati ma mio zio vabbè è stata
comunque una storia d'amore migliore di
quella di twilight
ce l'abbiamo l'ultima store ed è 5
non ci posso credere raga sacrificio
vulcanico completato 50 st wright stiamo
alla zona finale vai da lì ne vai da lì
vi che non la rivedo da secoli
ciao zio l'ho abbandonata da secoli
poverina vabbè non è migliorata la
situazione vede peggiorata scusami se ti
abbandonato ma dovevo farmi i cazzi miei
perfetto c'è qualcuno qui chi è questo
c'è armstrong bene è andato nello spazio
vai e saluta miliardi
bene benissimo che dovevo fare ciò che è
successo ho preso un jet set va bene
ragazzi
lily è andata completamente ci dovremmo
cosa se no io devo tornare con 60 st
wright ti prendi in giro io devo farmene
altre dieci
ma scherziamo anzi voglio che i ragazzi
allora facciamo così pensavo di finirlo
scrive l'ubs in questo episodio perché
devo farmene altre 10 this write ok non
lo farò perché il video uscirebbe di 14
ore e mezza anche perché non so quanto è
uscito questo e quindi per questo
episodio da kg qui non è ancora l'ultima
in prossimo sarà l'ultimo nome al solito
ragazzi 6 viso è piaciuto lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video tratto in
descrizione 6 st ancora i siti
iscrivetevi noi ci rivediamo il prossimo
vivo bene ragazzi